[Music]
breathless made you a star of the new
wave why do you think the French fell in
love with you they fell in love with the
character they get me instead and who is
that who is Jean Seberg
[Music]
million Americans look at you and they
see an escape they want the girl from
the Midwest America's Sweetheart I've
been trying to get away from that girl
my whole life this country is at war
with itself Vietnam the oppression of
black people in America it's the same
disgusting racism the revolution needs
movie stars who's that some artists just
grabbing some free publicity she has a
history of donations to civil rights
groups
she's a sympathizer sir I think she
could be useful you must be some kind of
crazy to come to this neighborhood and
that car was it my money were chasing
[Music]
[Music]
they've tapped our phones they're
listening I can hear these little clicks
on the line I think it's the government
where have you been I kept this late at
the office our job is to cheapen our
image in the eyes of the public there's
things that I've been ordered to do
those are pictures from our bedroom
are you having an affair they're pushing
her too hard she's coming apart this
comes from above
Seibert you gotta stop that will destroy
your reputation your family you can't
stand that I might be a part of
something more important than books or
articles or movies what are you a part
of except the end of two marriages who
is it
you swing by your limousine open your
legs and your checkbook and you think
that gives you the right to anything you
want I only ever wanted to help well
that doesn't make you a better person
that makes you a tourist to defame
somebody who speaks out against their
government is a type of persecution you
run around with a handful of nails
looking for a cross to die you deserve
to know the truth
woman has her secrets
[Music]
you